there are tech incubators all over the
world but you won't find many in a
neighborhood like this and the whole
point of this facility is that it's
meant to inspire the local youngsters
and give budding entrepreneurs in the
neighborhood some inspiration it's
called the idea Factory it's not a
factory designed to fill the next Google
or Facebook it focuses on things for
Chile and South America I showed up on a
demo day there was plenty of eye candy
but nothing beat this hello robots it's
like every other video conferencing
robot on a stick but this one is
basically leap
[Music]
that's so cool all of the gadgets come
from this man
rodrigo Quevedo he's something of a
local celebrity and has kanye west's
levels of passion for learning before so
let me mogul a son with colouring
intelligences I almost Al Gore it'll be
here but on moon don't say I give you a
nose again anyone else getting swole
okay man let's see that looks way more
it looking am i impressive here now well
I guess a Moe's solicit any yeah Rodrigo
was an officer in the Chilean army and
then an engineer until he had a
revelation and became a robotics
entrepreneur his most inspired invention
is this wheelchair people can control it
by tilting their head or making a
gesture soon Roderigo hopes it'll move
by thought alone by reading impulses
from a brainwave monitor familiar
Oh Thomas en de da mucho más pequeño
yeah tell him a mile of Oceana Rodriguez
helpers were surprisingly gentle as they
gave me the power of telekinesis in
Paris and that is it Emma that's how I
turn it on three blinks see it's like a
genie foot those crisps oh my god
[Music]
that's crazy it's amazing because fussy
[Music]
[Music]